thank God for that Keith Bradshaw is a
New York Times reporter and former
Detroit bureau chief high-and-mighty is
his new book on the proliferation of
sports utility vehicles or SUVs
he spoke recently at the Detroit
Athletic Club and an event sponsored by
the automobile Press Association for
about an hour
hi in my ear
SUVs the world's most dangerous vehicles
and how they got that way some people
say the the type the title doesn't leave
much to the imagination but let me just
briefly give an outline of the book
because I know that some of you haven't
had a chance to read it although I
gather there's an unsigned 15 page
attack on it that the auto industry has
put around which some of you may have
seen but for what the book says I try to
trace the history all the way back to
the 1920s in fact of the sport utility
vehicles and then make the case of why
the shift from in the United States from
our being a nation of car drivers to
increasingly a nation of sport utility
vehicle drivers is a dangerous trend I
in looking at the history I start off by
focusing on the why it was that vehicles
which had been on the market since the
1930s for example the Chevy Suburban
which came out in 1935 suddenly began
turning into family vehicles only really
in the 1970s and I attribute it partly
to a new vision in marketing and also to
a series of regulatory decisions
American Motors bought the Jeep brand in
1970 and really began for the first time
promoting it in a large-scale way to
urban and suburban buyers there had been
some efforts along these lines in the
1960s but American Motors really had the
muscle the marketing muscle the
dealership network to start selling a
lot of sport utility vehicles to urban
to urban buyers now what was also
happening in the 1970s that was also the
period when you had the big growth in
say
50 and environmental regulations and
American Motors was more poorly equipped
to meet the new regulations than were
any of the other automakers so they kept
asking for exceptions for the Jeeps
and they got them beginning with as I
described 1973 the Environmental
Protection Agency decided they would be
classified that sport utility vehicles
jeeps in particular would be classified
as non passenger vehicles and we're
lumped in with trucks and therefore they
were allowed to emit more air pollution
and to this day full-size sport utility
vehicles are allowed up to five and a
half times the air pollution per mile of
a car next 1976 the decision by the
Transportation Department to have the
sport utility vehicles classified as
light trucks also for fuel economy 1984
the sport utility vehicles were included
with light trucks as vehicles that could
be written off against your taxes very
easily and quickly by Realtors and so
forth even though car owners couldn't
was the beginning of the tax breaks that
were beginning that were pushing people
into sport utility vehicles 1990 the
luxury tax exempt on cars the luxury
cars that exempted the larger sport
utility vehicles and other light trucks
so I trace the development of this
tilted playing field in which there were
many preferences given to people who
bought sport utility vehicles instead of
cars then I go through what are the
drawbacks of having literally tens of
millions of American families now
driving sport utility vehicles instead
of cars and I try to address the myth
that sport utility vehicles are
especially green or good for the
environment while they're portrayed in
an outdoorsy way they do have the extra
air pollution they do have the inferior
fuel economy and then I also try to
address the the myth that they are safer
pointing out that the death rate is
higher per million registered vehicles
for sport utility vehicles for their
occupants mind you than it is for cars I
also talked about the the death rate for
other
occupants of other vehicles who were
struck by SUVs and SUVs nearly three
times as likely as a car to kill the
other occupant in a crash I finally I
trace the more recent development I look
at some of the marketing information the
automakers the own market research
showing that people who buy sport
utility vehicles are tend to be people
who are particularly worried about their
own needs and less concerned about those
of others
finally I bring it up to the presence I
talk about how there were efforts by a
Ford in particular to improve sport
utility vehicles to make them more
environmentally conscious to make them
safer but that Ford's brave attempt to
set a new direction for SUVs seems to
have faltered along with Ford's
difficulties of the firestone fiasco and
so that Ford seems to have lost its way
in many ways as the auto industry leader
on safety in their environment and
there's no clear leader in the industry
saying that SUVs must be made as safe as
cars must be made to have the same kind
of brakes as cars which they don't right
now must be made to say have the same
kind of handling as cars which they
don't right have right now finally in a
concluding chapter I talked about in
rather general terms about some
suggestions for the future I suggest
that since there are since we already
have graduated licenses driving licenses
for teens 16 year olds in many states
are not allowed to drive after dark or
after 10 o'clock at night or wood it
varies by state but I do say that teens
should not be learning to drive and
sport utility vehicles because they are
SUVs are less stable they are a less
vehicle that is less forgiving of
mistakes particularly teens have a high
proportion of single vehicle accidents
and you want a vehicle that is very
stable for something that is for a
teenager who's more prone to making the
mistakes that would result in a single
vehicle accident I have some rather
general comments on a few
economy although I don't make a specific
recommendation but do talk in terms of
whether it's a good idea to have cars
and support utility vehicles still
meeting very different standards I was
actually in Osaka Japan last Thursday
I'm now the Hong Kong bureau chief for
the New York Times and I was at the OPEC
meeting and I can tell you the open the
oil ministers there love American
gasoline consumption they were talking
about how the two main growth areas for
oil demand are China because its economy
is growing 7% a year and United States
gasoline consumption which is which has
been up very strongly part of that is
because more people are driving instead
of flying after September 11th but part
of it is also because the average fuel
economy of new vehicles sold in the
United States has been gradually
declining since 1987 and that decline is
mainly because of people switching out
of cars and into sport utility vehicles
so with that I'll open it up for
questions oh if I may add one other
thing as a former member of the all mode
of Press Association I should add the
the what we always what I guess was
always said which is if you quote
something from here be sure to measure
the automotive Press Association I knew
you were about to get that in
I do and this there are there different
trade-offs associated with different
sizes of sport utility vehicles I also
distinguish wherever the data allows me
between the the pickup truck based
models which are about eighteen and a
half percent of the market and still
growing now and the car based models
models like the Toyota Highlander which
is basically a modified Toyota Camry and
what I what I say is that all SUVs pose
problems relative to the comparable
comparably sized car for example the
smaller SUVs or have particularly high
rollover rates part of that of course is
driver behavior most crashes involve
partly a mistake by the driver the only
question is how forgiving is the vehicle
of driver error
I also the very different way in which
sport utility vehicles are regulated
that the larger you make a sport utility
vehicle
the more rules you get out of for
example once you get it over six
thousand pounds gross vehicle weight
which would be anything a little larger
than an explorer then you are exempted
from the from the luxury tax exempted
from the accelerated depreciation caps
that fall on cars you get your allowed
more air pollution once you get over six
thousand pounds once you get over eighty
five hundred pounds gross vehicle weight
which would be your next larger which
would be your very large SUVs like the
excursion then you're allowed even more
air pollution and you're totally exempt
from the fuel economy standards by
contrast it doesn't matter how big big
you build a car you're still subject to
the to the same standards now these
weight based the weight based regulatory
systems as we all know in this room is a
legacy of their being regulated as
trucks but the question is to what
extent it makes sense
still if these are being used by most
people as all turn
tips to the family car thank you and I
do actually use awards data repeatedly I
think you're still with warts Awards has
been the leader in distinguishing
actually between the car based models
they and the the pickup based models so
you really haven't had a lot of car
based models until fairly recently
beginning in late 1996 but I think it is
it a useful distinction some groups some
of the data agencies and some of the
federal data does not distinguish now
fortunately you can still look at for
example crash data and say that this
represents pickup based sport utility
vehicles because if you look at the
registered vehicles numbers over 95% of
the registered SUVs in this country are
still pickup based SUVs yes well thank
you it's good to be back yes could you
tell me a little bit more about how you
psycho analyze the typical SUV buyer and
how you got the data to fit in order to
shame them singers well thank you I'll
read the passage unfortunately in this
unsigned criticism that got circulated
of me by the auto industry it cuts off
the quote before it says who the quote
is coming from so I'll read the quote
who has been buying SUVs since
automakers turned them into family
vehicles they tend to be people who are
insecure in vain
they are frequently nervous about their
marriages and uncomfortable about
parenthood they often lack black
confidence than their driving skills
above all they are apt to be
self-centered and self-absorbed with
little interest in their neighbors or
communities now that's where the auto
industry document then cut off the quote
but the next sentence was no that's not
a cynic talking that's the auto
industry's own market researchers and
executives and I then go on to give a
variety of quotes from from people on
how SUVs are marketed that the people
who are buying sport utility vehicles
tend to be a self-oriented is the is the
catch phrase that one gets
a lot from the from the marketers I
quote David Bostwick the market research
director at Chrysler who talks about how
quote we have a basic resistance in our
society to admitting that we are parents
and no longer able to go out and find
another mate if you have a sport utility
you can have the smoked windows put the
children in the back and pretend you're
still single also also from that also
from Bostwick of Chrysler quote sport
utility people say I already have two
kids I don't need twenty unquote and
they quote then we talked to the people
who have minivans and they say I don't
have two kids I have twenty all the kids
in the neighborhood I quote Tom Eliot
Honda's executive vice president for
North American operations though the
people who quote the people who buy SUVs
are in many cases buying the outside
first and then the inside they are
buying the image of the SUV first and
then the functionality now it is not new
to sell automobiles as image vehicles
what I point out in this and it's based
on a story I did in partly on a story I
did in 2000 which none of the auto
industry executives questioned at the
time either it's that the auto industry
does enormous amounts of market research
with surveys sizes of as much as a
hundred thousand people and that Dwarfs
anything we do as media organizations
which tend to be public opinion polls
based on talking to a thousand people
and what they do is they some of you
know is looking at the kinds of
activities that people engage in and the
activity lists for SUVs tend to have
less of an emphasis on family oriented
activities or less than emphasis on
things like volunteer work particularly
in comparison to minivans in fact just
as the best way to find out what's going
on at Chrysler is often to ask General
Motors the best way to find out what's
going on inside the automakers with
sport utility vehicles is to ask the car
guys in minivan guys because they know
exactly what the research shows
and are quite willing to say and you can
see the the results or the application
of that research then in a lot of the
advertising which caters to often the
rather aggressive mentality like the
Cadillac Escalade ad that shows a it
shoot it takes a picture of the Escalade
sort of from a point below the hood in
front of the grille it's hurtling at you
you may have seen this one the trees on
a sort of dark and stormy night or
whistling by it it looks like what you'd
see if you are sitting in your car and
you turn and it's just about to come
through your side side window and it
says right underneath that rather than
menacing photo yield an inch high
letters and then it talks about move
immediately to the right and below that
and then there's a little bit of text
and then it says it's good to be the
Cadillac
well that is appealing to a to a self
oriented audience that that is
particularly interested in being the
Cadillac in that context but whether
it's not suggesting it's good to be the
Cadillac in a moral sense of of goodness
it's it's suggesting a sort of survival
of the fittest approach to to the
American Road yes
for most people is between an SUV and a
minivan but you keep focusing on what
amounts to small cars versus two very
large SUV's and the noise doesn't seem
to be a read very rational no I don't in
the book I strongly recommend so that's
absolutely not true in the book I
strongly recommend large cars
I do not large cars and minivans yes
and while some of the crossover utility
vehicles are now moving towards the
minivans they're still the bulk of the
SUV market is still your pickup based
models they still tend to have taller
hoods than the minivans which means
there's more danger to other other road
users because they'll taller the hood
the more likely it is to catch you in
the neck or in the head if you're struck
from the side when you're in a car
the SUV still tend to have worst gas
mileage higher emissions mainly because
they're heavier so but in the book I
very much but I particularly praise
large cars and I give what some might
view is an almost nostalgic praise of
large cars for their handling for their
braking capability that they meet the
interests in the needs of of many
families in a very practical way they
get great fuel efficiency I don't think
the Detroit auto industry has gotten
nearly enough credit in the general
public for both cleaning up the air
pollution and improving the gas mileage
of large cars I point out in my book
that for example the current Chrysler
Concorde full-size car has as much
interior room as a 1978 Chrysler New
Yorker luxury sedan and yet it gets as
good gas mileage as a 1978 dodge omni
hatchback so I used that as an example
of the tremendous progress that's been
made in large cars and yet I point out
however that instead of buying the the
Chrysler Concorde Chrysler customers
having larger numbers been buying
Durango SUVs which get exactly the same
gas mileage is that 1978 chrysler new
yorker luxury sedan so i I do praise the
large cars large cars unfortunately got
typecast as big dirty gas guzzlers for
an older generation though which isn't
fair large cars even the largest cars
are subject to the same air pollution
rules as small cars and I try very hard
to stay away from saying small cars
because something people try to
characterize me as pushing people out of
SUVs into small cars that's not the
choice the choice there are still large
cars that provide great handling great
braking excellent fuel economy
particularly by historical standards
virtually no air pollution and people
just aren't buying them but because they
may not understand how good they are
three choices have always been station
wagons many vans and SUVs you're really
looking at they it's much different than
the sedan so-called car market um it's
it's true that if you have a lot of
stuff to carry particularly the larger
family you're gonna end up aiming for
one of those but I mean wagons are
beginning to come back and your
full-size cars you can you get good
performance in a in a larger wagon as
well one of the sad parts has been the
decline of full-size wagons you see a
lot of the mid-sized wagons now not a
lot of full-size wagons but then I also
recommend minivans and I talked quite a
bit about the sort of the contrast
between SUV and mini SUV and minivan
buyers and to some extent between the
vehicles now some people say well isn't
the SUV market moving into minivans or
but aren't they becoming minivans but
again the the proportion or the the
percent of the market that is pickup
based SUVs is still gradually growing
and then on top of that you've got this
share of car based crossover utility
vehicles that are increasingly minivan
like and those people are coming out of
cars and coming out of minivans and into
these cross review Atilla t vehicles
which still have the higher
than most minivans and may not be still
quite as practical still still tend in
some cases to have higher floors so
you're live giving up some functionality
some accessibility the automakers
categorizing SUV owners as vain and
insecure etc because you don't quote
from any market research and I'm kind of
curious what you've seen and and and how
you arrived at that conclusion and in
fact you believe that SUV owners are
vain and I think that in any large group
of people you will get a tremendous
variety so that certainly you get
extremely some extremely modest people
who drive SUVs and you will get some
extremely secure people who drive SUVs
all that I say is what they tend to be
and in that I am relying on the auto
industry's own experts on the theory
that they tend to have more of an
understanding of their market than
others I mean for example I cited the
the honda quote on the people who are
buying the image of the SUV first and
then the functionality are the people
who buy SUVs are in many cases buying
the outside first and then the inside
trading off practicality in favor of how
other people see you which I also is I
mean to some extent certainly you see
that in the sports car market as well
but it's something that definitely in
the case of the SUV market you've got
you've got an image thing going I mean
you talk and I'm sure you've had the
same conversations that a lot of the a
lot of the auto marketers and designers
talk about how SUVs are designed for the
for the person who one week a year might
be engaged in an adventurous activity or
doing the off-road driving and that one
week a year as I quote another executive
saying is central to that person's
self-image they may be in a desk job
before 49 or 50 weeks a year and then
they spend a week or two a year visiting
the relatives but that one week a year
is the week for which they they they buy
this in this vehicle so it's it's it's
because it preserves an image it's it's
it's appealing to their to their
self-image if I can actually pause at
this point I was wondering who here
would take the decide that it is a good
idea to be moving a very large
percentage of the American driving
public out of cars and into particularly
the pickup based SUVs since that's now
at 18.6% i think of the market and still
rising suvs are only ten percent of
registered vehicles so we've barely
begun to see just how big a boom this is
going to be but who thinks these are
that this is a good idea to have this
kind of very large shift in what America
drives well I think that makes the to
some extent the point the reality is
that people are buying them and it's
more than just image its functionality
people buy large SUVs so that they can
tow their boat to the cottage on the
weekend they toast snowmobiles in the
winter they tow their dirt bikes you
know I mean it's not just an empty box
that they're buying for show thank you
and that's an excellent point and one
which I I forgot to mention so let me
mentioned that in other conversations
and I I've talked about this book many
times so I sometimes forget that point I
do say in the book that some people need
SUVs we had the government designed
those large sedans that you
and people find those boring and so you
know just like with any regulation
people are going to find their way
around it and what they found is that
SUVs answer their needs in more ways
than one
in image and in functionality but nobody
wants to buy a boring sedan anymore you
know well what I I do say in the book
that some people need SUVs and that we
there is definitely a need for SUVs
among a segment fairly large segment of
the population but nothing like as large
as the number of people who are now
getting SUVs you've got four starters
about 1% of the population that does
serious off-road driving of the sort but
it's just not going to work to do in a
car now there are numbers as high as 13%
of SUV owners go off-road at some point
but that's if you include things like
driving down a smoothly graded dirt road
in the summer when it's dry you don't
need an SUV for that but you do have
this small segment that likes to go
off-road likes to engage in serious
off-road driving you have a much larger
segment which you just mentioned of
people who tow and you look at the at
the activity analyses of the automakers
with these hundred thousand person
sample sizes and they show somewhere
around 20 percent of SUV owners use them
for towing occasionally for some of the
largest models that gets up to 40 45
percent but the the question is I think
it is a fair question as to whether it
is a good idea to be shifting huge
numbers of people out of cars and into
sport utility vehicles particularly
since I don't think a lot of people in
the general public understand the
shortcomings of SUV and the number one
example I would use in a place where I
think for example that the automotive
press can make a positive difference for
safety is breaking I can't tell you how
many people I have met over the years
who think that four-wheel drive helps
you stop and as we all know in this room
but I don't know that the general public
knows of for will Drive means you've got
the engine turning all four wheels it is
in some ways dangerous to offer or to
have four-wheel drive
or drivers who think well I managed to
get out of my driveway and onto the
street without slipping and sliding once
therefore I don't have to go as slowly
as I used to go in my car the brake
industry the anti-lock brake industry
has really done a good public education
effort to tell people look when you
press down on the brake and you've got
anti-lock brakes it's going to start
bumping up and down very hard
that doesn't mean you let your foot off
the brake you push it down really hard
and you keep it down and the analog
brake industry has done a good job
getting that message out who is putting
out the comparable message that a
four-wheel drive does not help your
brakes that if anything in fact the
average stopping distances in SUVs are
longer than they are in cars you barely
see that and I quote to hell in Petroski
us before she retired as Ford's vice
president for safety environment saying
that is something that needs to be told
more to drivers but you still don't see
it in fact if anything you have ads now
that seem to stress the braking
capability of SUVs now some people can
defend that as saying well that's
because SUV brakes have improved but it
is still a dangerous business to be
telling people this SUV has great brakes
without reminding them that four-wheel
drive is not something that helps you
stop here today there was the young man
from Grosse Pointe went to court and
that had killed was it he killed two and
per critically injured a third or
permanently the guy the kid's gonna be
disabled for life and he was driving
with it a Tahoe or a Chevy Blazer at 70
miles an hour through a sign on a street
15 years old
I'm sorry I know that could very well if
he'd been driving his daddy's Lincoln
Continental instead just a hypothesis
what did it bet is bad
um that's the question would he have
lost control of the vehicle if he had
been driving a Lincoln Continental it's
hard to say in any single accident and
if it's at 70 miles an hour if you do
Lowe's control the vehicle your survival
chances are extremely low even if you're
wearing your seat belt even if you've
got a knee airbag but the question is
would he have kept control of the
vehicle or not now in any one accidents
hard to know for sure but certainly I
think many people here have written
reviews saying that the handling of the
Ness UV is not as good as a car that it
is a harder vehicle to control and
that's one of the reasons why I do
suggest that an SUV is not a suitable
first vehicle for in this case a 15 year
old to be basically learning to drive on
it is a big extremely powerful truck in
most cases and it needs to be treated
with the respect of a truck sorry you've
had up your hands mention technologies
and braking technologies you make a big
issue about that about the truck braking
especially being behind the times are
those catching up to the problems Keith
that you see with SUVs are they gonna
eliminate the concerns you have about
SUVs as suspension technologies and
braking technologies come online or not
I mentioned in the book that the there
has been improvement certainly if I if
somebody were to say to me I absolutely
positively am going to buy a sport
utility vehicle I would say be extra
careful of the older models the newer
models are better and one of the areas
in which they are better is in the
brakes the automakers were very late in
buying the best brake technology for
their SUVs because for many years they
were still building them on the same
under bodies as the pickups and the
pickups tend to be a very low margin
business in which you tend to put very
cheap brakes the while you are seeing
also for example improvements in load
leveling suspension technology which is
probably what your loo
one of the problems with breaking any
very heavy fairly high vehicle is the is
that you get some forward lean when
you're trying to brake hard and that
means you're relying even more on the
front wheels to stop you on the front
brakes and they're the the suspension
industry and the brake industry has
worked hard on this but we've gotten to
the point now where on on dry ground
you're talking an extra whatever it may
be depending on whether you're looking
at Consumer Reports data or Car and
Driver magazine data an extra four seven
feet of stopping distance at sixty miles
an hour in an SUV but you still end up
with often very long stopping distances
for a fully loaded sport utility vehicle
particularly on the wet I cite the
example in here where there were tests
done by the government at the US Army
facility in Aberdeen Maryland in which
the car stopped in a hundred and sixty
five hundred and seventy feet and the
fully loaded Ford Expedition went 210
220 feet on average in a dozen tests so
but even more dangerous I think than
differences in stopping distance is
awareness is its consumer education I
mean there's been to come back to the
analog break point there's had to be a
huge effort to tell people that how to
use anti-lock brakes and I haven't seen
that kind of an effort as far as warning
people that you've got to be careful
barreling down the road in a sport
utility vehicle on on wet or snowy
ground because it is not going to help
you stop it's just going to help you go
even faster we're all coming back to
this thought for a page or two in the
book Keith you take the automotive press
to task for being hesitant to criticize
the industry both in SUVs and and other
things I think you talked about Detroit
being kind of an insular market in the
way that the industry is covered more so
than other media by people who've been
doing it for a long time
and
and press people who are coddled by the
companies they cover a little bit more
than its not a lot more than other
industries do you think the automotive
press corps as a group has an ethical
dilemma I think any time that that
whenever you cover the same issue in a
company town for many many years you
always have to give yourself a check
sort of how do I stay independent the I
also say in the book that I don't think
the way vehicles are reviewed is helpful
enough to the readers the auto industry
as I point out in the book tends to do
ride and drive a test drives ticket
reporters on test drives of SUVs that
involve quite a bit of off-road driving
and quite a bit of driving in fairly
remote areas and that's not
representative of the way a lot of these
vehicles are actually used let's say
you've got 900 words in which to review
a vehicle if 300 words of that is an
assessment of its off-road driving
capability even though a tiny fraction
of the buyers are actually gonna use
that off-road driving capability that's
300 words that otherwise probably would
have been used to say things like it
doesn't have the handling of a car or it
doesn't have the the braking capability
of a car they're not being measured
enough to the same standards that cars
are as far as the the as far as just the
the general difficulty of staying
independent of the industry also I
remember in 1997 I wrote a bunch of
stories saying that there was a problem
with sport utility vehicles hitting cars
with the front ends of the vehicles
riding over the bumpers and door sills
of the cars and at that time the auto
industry sort of said hmm but it was the
auto writers who were the main critics
of this concern the main defenders of
the industry then and the auto industry
you
out and in fact I look at the widespread
use now of hollow steel bars below and
behind the bumper I mean it was it was a
important change so it's just a question
I think if you cover any industry you
you have to always sort of check
yourself and remind yourself I'm not
part of the the industry and I think you
have to it's it's extra difficult if
you're in a company town which is as car
oriented as this town is now that said
many people are extremely objective and
the hard-hitting reporters about the
auto industry
Katie Kirtland of Businessweek is
probably my favorite auto writer for
giving giving you all the facts in
Businessweek about what's really going
on in the industry and many of you many
the rest of you also have done a
terrific job on these things yes Mike
but as I'm sure your you would agree is
that a lot of the sale of vehicles is
based on image and perhaps you miss
menacing image you talk about actually
an asset example is it going to be
enough to kind of and the reason to get
it out of midsize cars and large cars
and minivans because Dan somewhat of a
Doughty image or something so so how how
do you think in the future people might
get back into those segments unless is
the recitation of all these facts enough
to do that or is there gonna be some
sort of try to change the image
those vehicles the SUV boom-lay is here
to stay so many factories have been
converted to SUV production that even if
you saw some flattening and demand you'd
still have just as many SUVs or
practically as many SUVs produced it's
just that they would begin discounting
them somewhat in fact we've seen a bit
of this already when auto sales began
flagging somewhat last year right after
September 11th
General Motors introduced 0% financing
across the board including on SUVs on
which they hadn't previously offered
discounts what happened SUV sales went
through the roof and there is a because
the profit margins are so large on SUVs
there is so much room for discounting if
necessary that I think we're just going
to see ever more SUVs so what's needed
though is an educated consumer and a
continued and if anything stepped-up
effort by the auto industry to make
these vehicles as appropriate as
possible for family users I mentioned in
the book a General Motors exact a senior
at General Motors executive engineer of
whom I interviewed in December of 97 who
talked about if we make twenty thousand
SUVs of a given model and one of them is
going to be used for racing on dirt
racing on the Baja Peninsula we need to
make all 20,000 with that capability so
that we can accommodate all buyers and
that's the kind of mentality that has
gone into a lot of SUV design but there
are real trade-offs when you're
designing vehicles or off-road driving
and heavy duty use of that sort that
make them somewhat less practical for
the kind of street driving that most of
the buyers are going to use them for yes
we saw in Europe the so-called boost
test because Mercedes to hold up
introduction of hey I believe it was the
m-class
and they saw it in class the class yes
they seem to solve that in part at least
by using electronic stability control
now now we're seeing things like
rollover protection will that be a big
factor in the problems that you cite
those kinds of things one of the things
that I recommend in my book is that
consumers need to be aware of and take
advantage of some of the new technology
that's becoming available the stability
control systems appear to really make a
difference in fact I have test driven a
Mercedes m-class with the stability
control on and off and boy what a
difference it made I found myself
tipping up slightly on two wheels
turning on a wet surface when the
stability control was not engaged I was
able to keep all four wheels on the
ground when it was engaged
so these stability control systems are
important what is unfortunate is that
stability control was seen by the auto
industry as another luxury autumn
another luxury option that was rolled
out first on the luxury cars because
that's where everything appears first
and then it's been spreading to to SUVs
and it's something that really is it
shouldn't be viewed as a luxury option
if you should be viewed as a safety item
that is important and should be
available as soon as possible on as many
SUVs as possible now Ford has taken the
lead on that Ford has said that Ford
said it on I think August 8 mm - I that
it would make stability control
available on every SUV model within five
years now why do I remember that date
because it was the date of the that
Firestone and Ford announced the same
day in Washington that they were
recalling Firestone tires and it was
missed in that in that hullabaloo I
wrote a story about it in fact that day
ik I buried on an inside page of the
business section and it was but it was
important and there been a number of
initiatives particularly by Ford
towards saying look we're going to make
all this technology available to try to
improve
vehicles I think also affords promise at
the Detroit Auto Show in 2001 to make
the brakes on SUVs as effective as the
brakes on cars within a few years and
that's something that needs doing
finally I would mention that people need
to be more aware of the value of side
airbags I mean side airbags should
become standard equipment on is why the
range of cars as possible because there
is such an increased risk now of having
a tall front-end vehicle coming through
your window that you've got to be
protected now that said people also need
to remember that they're no safer in the
vehicle with the tall front end because
of the some of the other dangers
associated with them Frank I'm hearing
two different tracks here because on the
one hand you know we have have the
social ills of SUVs versus the safety
you can make them you can make an SUV as
safe as you like there's still the
social of your burns more gas it
pollutes more it's questionable whether
a Lincoln Continental would look as
invited to a drunk fifteen year old as a
big SUV yes so III guess what I'm asking
you is it as someone who is trapped SUVs
for five years
one more which is which is the bigger
evil the the safety issues or the social
issues you know that is a really really
good question Frank
it's one that I really struggled with in
my book because one of the questions is
where do you end up on a fuel economy
small cars that are very nimble can
avoid a lot of crashes but there is
still some evidence that they are going
to be less safe because they don't have
the mass in hitting roadside objects a
large car might knock down a two or
three a thick two or three inch thick
trunk tree and the small car might not
and have a real crash out of it so where
I end up coming down in the book is sort
of a balance on that in the sense that
the extra safe do you get from
additional weight flattens between 3,500
and 4,000 pounds above 3,500 to 4,000
pounds which is the weight of a large
car or midsize SUV the death rates don't
get any lower for the occupants but they
sure keep increasing for the other guy
you hit and so what I do suggest in the
book is that if safety is a priority
then you would want to pay particular
attention to fuel economy rules for
vehicles over 4,000 pounds now that said
the environmental movement does not like
that part of my book at all but there
are some trade-offs now you get into the
other questions though I mean air
pollution and and saving oil do you how
much do you worry about our reliance on
Middle Eastern oil does that in the long
term become a safety issue if it
increases the percentage likelihood of
military conflicts in the Middle East
which could result in American lives I
mean there's so many trade-offs that
it's the trade-offs that that everybody
has to make but so I basically say look
look let's try to address as much as
possible all of the issues both safety
and environmental and oil oil import
issues but in some cases there are trade
offs or interactions between those
issues and then it's just a question of
as a society what is the best balance to
strike and I like my conclusions chapter
is fairly cautious I also say that look
Detroit is so dependent on sport utility
vehicles now economically that we cannot
have drastic changes so it's just a
question of striking an acceptable
balance between safety environmental
concerns national security concerns and
just economic and financial importance
terms the mold of Ralph Nader or did you
write this book in the mindset that you
might write a story for The Times
because it seems and most of the reviews
people sort of position you as a an
advocate or or somebody who's
prosecuting a case and maybe picking
facts selectively you've been criticized
for that and I just want to hear your
response this is absolutely not
a written as a story for the New York
Times this book is purely my own project
any and all opinions in it that I
expressed or my own and this is a
journalistic expose that definitely
makes editorial points in favor of
improvements you see like a third market
emerging like BMWs come out with the x5
which is a sport activity vehicle it's
not it's designed to do off-road but
handles very well in road conditions
also Subarus coming out with vehicle
that's a an automotive platform with a
pickup do you see a third market that
might be some type of hybrid that's
between a sport utility and
either a car or minivan that's somewhere
in the middle yes I do and I have a
whole chapter on them I I described them
including for example the x5 as a
crossover utility vehicles or car based
sport utility vehicles again this would
be like the Toyota Highlander being
based on a on a Toyota Camry essentially
being a tall - a Camry now some people
have said don't worry about the problems
the sport utility vehicles they're just
turning into modified cars anyway
they're just turning into modified
minivans anyway the numbers don't show
that what the numbers show is that the
proportion of the market that is still
pick up based SUVs is still just about
one in five new vehicles and it's still
growing gradually and then on top of
that you have these crossover utility
vehicles and they are displacing cars
they're basically catering to people who
find the traditional sport utility
vehicles to trucky too tall too lousy
brakes too poor handling and there's
something in between are they as good as
a full-size - sedan or station wagon not
necessarily because of this problem of
they are slightly taller you see a lot
of large cars that get 5 stars in the
National Highway Traffic Safety
Administration ratings of how vulnerable
vehicles are to rollovers there are no
crossover utility vehicles yet they have
gotten that fifth star there have been a
few that have gotten four stars and I
would think to the Pontiac Aztek for
example a much unloved vehicle but one
that nonetheless is did manage that
fourth star so they do tend to do better
than for example the pickup based models
which tend to get two or three stars or
even a lowly one star they are a any
intermediate step and should be viewed
as something in between yes
again concentrate on SUVs rather than
pickup trucks which have exactly the
same
issues good question I talked about that
a couple of times in the book pickup
trucks are still serve a strong
commercial purpose they've served that
purpose for 60 or 70 years they are
needed by so many businesses that you do
need to make some allowances for them
and I talk in the book for example about
how if rules are to be tightened for
sport utility vehicles you'd probably
want to make an exception for vehicles
with an open bed that is at least six
feet long which would you I say six feet
to or six feet or six and a half feet to
distinguish from vehicles that otherwise
might you might just like take the take
the lid off the trunk and call it a
truck if you didn't have some kind of
definition of how long the bed should be
but there is there is a legitimate need
to transport goods and pickup trucks
fall into that well but the there you're
always going to have people who need to
carry big bulky stuff and it's some of
these rules I make this distinction on
on fuel economy you could see I mean
certainly there would be given the role
of our problem in pickups as well you
could see a need for the for more
stability control systems on pickups
there's one of the hard things about
analyzing pickups is that they have a
different category of drivers from the
SUV's so for example some people will
say look pickups have higher death rates
for their occupants then do SUVs or cars
but pickups skew very very heavily
towards male drivers left in younger
male drivers and so you're getting a
driver behavior factor in there
by contrast what is surprising about the
fact that SUVs have higher death rates
for their occupants than car cars have
for their occupants is that SUVs are
such a safe cautious bunch of drivers
right now I mean the SUV market right
now is mainly middle aged families who
aren't driving out at 3 and 4 a.m. when
the death rates more than quadruple on
the roads
they're people who have great credit
there's a big dispute right now in the
insurance industry on whether to charge
higher insurance premiums for people who
have poor credit because of some
correlations there you can see a lot of
social reasons why you wouldn't want to
do that for insurance premiums but older
vehicles tend to be bought by younger
drivers for example teens have poor
credit and right now they can't afford
to be buying a sport utility vehicle
they can't afford one usually unless
their parents or grandparents buy one
for them but as more SUVs end up in the
used vehicle market as that as older
SUVs become a greater percentage of all
SUVs on the road you're gonna have more
and more of a problem with that
similarly this is a separate issue from
the teens and that's saying drunk
drivers are separate question I'm not
saying teens are drunks which is what
somebody was claiming or I guess the
auto industry criticism the anonymous
criticism of me was claiming but drunk
drivers are particularly repeated drunk
offenders are especially likely to drive
vehicles with a price tag of a thousand
dollars in glass real clunkers there
have been programs in various states to
confiscate the automobiles of people who
are convicted a second or third time of
drunk driving those programs have not
even paid their own administrative costs
because the vehicles they're
confiscating are so cheap it doesn't
even cover the cost of storing it and
processing it you've got all these 500
and $800 fifteen year old cars now
heaven forbid when those end up being a
five hundred and eight hundred dollar
fifteen and twenty year old sport
utility vehicles with even worse
functioning or poorly maintained breaks
than they have now so I think you there
is sort of this question of it's it's
hard to assess the it's hard to compare
directly the SUV and pickup markets and
things like for example traffic death
numbers because of this difference in
driving them at some point the insurers
are going to have to take into account
the greater deadliness of sport utility
vehicles now right now I talked about
this some in the book but just to
explain it simply right now you pay for
collision and comprehensive insurance
collision as for when you get in a wreck
and if you get your vehicle fixed
comprehensive it is for fire and theft
that is adjusted right now based on what
model you buy if you buy a Porsche
there's all kinds of evidence that shows
that Porsches are more likely to be
stolen and you are going to pay extra
per thousand dollars of value of that
Porsche compared to how much you're
going to pay per thousand dollars of
value for a Mercury Grand Marquis
full-size car the insurance companies
with few exceptions don't adjust how
much insurance you pay based on what
model vehicle you buy which is a huge
subsidy from the car draw in drivers who
are getting gouged by the insurance
companies and that money is being
basically transferred to the SUV owners
they base the insurance companies put
all the money into one big pool and they
make the payments out of it but they're
dividing up who share who how large the
payments are you have to make in the
pool without respect to what kind of the
vehicle you're driving now the insurance
industry's own highway loss data
Institute calculated in 1994 that a
full-size SUV is going costs about
eighty inflex about 80 percent more
property damage losses liability losses
for the insurers to cover per year than
the typical car are they charging
eighty percent more for that full-sized
SUVs
property damage liability insurance no
even if they were to fully adjust it
wouldn't be an 80% increase mind you
because nearly half of the insurance is
just administrative costs and overhead
and so forth and then the other half is
the accost of actually paying the claims
but there is still considerable room for
the insurance companies to adjust what
they charge for liability insurance and
that would be a very constructive step
forward because let's say you've got the
forty five-year-old safe driver and the
16 year old if you put that forty
five-year-old safe driver into a and
he's choosing between a full-size SUV
and a mid-sized car and then his insure
tells him what we're gonna charge you an
extra thirty percent a year for choosing
the full-size SUV for your liability
insurance if he's only paying 200 year
in liability insurance anyway it's not
that big a different deal you're not
interfering with consumer choice on the
other hand for that teenager you
probably don't want in the full-size SUV
anyways for safety reasons a 30%
increase in his liability insurance is
going to be a bundle and so the
insurance industry can I think make a
positive contribution to the - to
traffic safety in fact in my book I even
suggest that car drivers ask their
insurance agent
am I getting a break for the fact that
I'm not driving an SUV and if they're
not getting a break they should think
about asking other insurers if they can
get a better break elsewhere Keith
Bradshaw currently serves as the New
York Times hongkong bureau chief
high-and-mighty SUVs the world's most
dangerous vehicles and how they got that
way is published by public